Quit your job and go start it.
Yes,
there are characteristics for people who
are good at entrepreneurs.
They quit their job and they go start
it.
I'm gonna sit next to a lovely woman
wants.
And uh,
she had a fantastic idea for a,
for a company and said,
well,
how long have you been designing it?
And,
and whatnot.
She said,
18 months and said,
well look,
I'll give you a bit of bit of advice.
You know,
like,
yeah,
put down your fork and knife.
We've breakfast,
go to your office,
lock the door,
throw your three colleagues.
Nobody's allowed to leave the room.
You have to order in pizza and beer and
soda and whatever else it is until you
finish the product and its life.
If you don't do that,
you will never be successful.
If you do it,
you have a shot,
right?
And you have a shot to fail,
which is,
you know,
that's a,
that's a better starting point than
never even having a shot to,
uh,
to fail.
Uh,
so she didn't do it.
Somebody else along,
a couple of other companies launch the
same product.
She actually never got out the out the
door.
So if you want to be an entrepreneur,
quit your job right now.
Shut down this browser after you
patronize big things,
advertisers first and go start it now.
Why you still looking at me?
Go start it now.